add insane value so one of the
consistent messages on my channel is
that you need to add a lot about you got
to add insane value if you want to make
a lot of money than you need to add
value to your customers people have busy
lives they have lots of things on the go
they're not going to remember you unless
you give them a real reason it's not
that they don't think you're good they
think you're good but they've got a lot
of good stuff happen in their life for
you to break through all the noise and
clutter in somebody's life it needs to
be crazy good it's got to be insane it's
got to be off the charts extraordinary
and so that's the challenge for
entrepreneurs is creating that culture
so that we're giving them giving our
customer something extraordinary so when
I get to my book obviously there's been
a lot of insane value that I put into
the book it's a it's a massive labor of
love it's not just something that I'm
trying to mail in and capitalize on my
audience and say go buy this and it's a
piece of crap there's life changing
stuff in that book that I'm really
really proud of but we won't be able to
really see it you guys won't be able to
see the value until it comes out until
you have it in your hands until you're
able to kind of work through the
exercises and so we're putting the value
and now is in the bonuses where my idea
with the bonus is for people who buy
copies of the book everybody who buys
i'm making a thank you video even a
quick short thank you video to recognize
them and say i really appreciate it it's
going above and beyond and some people
are just buying the book just so that
they can get to thank you video but in
that thank you video I want to share two
clips of people have have used one from
Ryan who put that video up on his
YouTube channel to help me promote the
book totally unsolicited all his idea
and another from Robin who's a who's a
customer from New Zealand who made up
her own video on her channel to thank me
for the video and I'll share those two
clips and hopefully you can go and check
out will link up the channels below to
you can go check them out what I want
for you guys is to create something that
people then want to create around there
Ivan critter on the book yet they're
just screwing around the thank you video
that I made now they want to create
videos and so are people creating videos
for you are they creating tribute videos
are they creating product review videos
is your stuff touching them in such a
way
a that they want to create content to
help you and give you more exposure so
it's working for me with ryan and robin
and a few others and hopefully work for
you and let's roll the clips hi even
this is Robin in New Zealand I just
wanted to take the time to say thank you
so much for all the work you do and for
acknowledging me that was a great little
video you sent and thanks for the
shoutout that's coming up you've changed
my life I don't leave things to chance
anymore I'm getting up I've got a great
morning routine going on and I'm seeing
the results so thank you so much for all
the work you do and please come and
visit us down here in New Zealand we'd
love it I live in a particularly
beautiful part of the world it's in the
South Island near to Queenstown and we
have amazing scenery like this I don't
know if you can see that very well but
there we go and there's lots going on
here a lot of entrepreneurial stuff from
way back and that would be great so
thanks again bye
Ryan what's up happy what day is it
today happy Tuesday happy Tuesday really
appreciate the order of the book means
alot to me that you can support me there
another order from Texas is a lot of
people from Texas picking up the book of
my agents in Texas so feel like I got to
make it out the Texas one of these days
to say hi to you guys and maybe go meet
up or something but that happens I will
let you know but you want to give a
quick shout out really appreciate your
support love to know what you think when
the book comes out thanks again man
continue to believe I'll see you soon
so hopefully you guys enjoyed Thank You
Ryan and Robin feeling the love and for
everybody else who's been a part of the
book launch so far your help has been
massively appreciated and we still have
we still have a long ways to go so
hopefully I can continue to count on
that support so let's get to the update
how we're doing on the book where we're
going and answer your questions so right
now we're at we are at 141 sales we are
still very far short of our 3,000 goals
so hopefully you guys watching well will
help me get there one again the book is
just a massive value it's helped me
build the empire that that I built up
but also looking at other companies
we've gone from 50,000 although we up to
hundreds of millions of dollars by
having self-awareness so if you feel
like you're not quite sure what you
staying for you feel like you do know
what you say form you don't know how to
best apply it people don't care enough
about what you're you're creating then I
think it's gonna be a book that would
really help you and if you've enjoyed
the videos that I've given you know for
free for you guys and you want to help
out a little bit it'd really mean a lot
to me let's try to get those numbers a
little bit higher sitting here at 141
now so the goal is three thousand by
december six so we still have some time
but i'd like to get a little bit closer
to that goal you guys watching show a
little bit of love for Evan if you can
what's the questions so first thing I'm
noticing is a whole bunch of Jason
questions getting Jason I can we want
Jason Jason feeling the love jason is
not here with me today so I'm feeling
about myself but i'll make sure to pass
on those messages to him and keep it
coming we'll get him on camera one of
these days first up is patrick when will
it be out on iBooks would really like
the audio version that's a great
question i don't know if it's up on
iBooks I know it's up an audible and we
begin a number of sales from audible so
oh that's a great question I will ask my
mom the shirt and forward on that
message to them and again if you guys
aren't able to access it somewhere that
you normally buy books link it up let me
know and i'll forward on that
information so we get moving with the
publisher next up our June please make
this book available on amazon india
again like the last one you can't get it
where you normally buy books I'm every
week I send those comments under the
publisher and I put the pressure from
you guys that's how we got the audio
book released early because you guys
send in comments so keep a comment we
got I books and amazon india this
somewhere else that we're not in let me
know link it up and i'll continue to
push that horse next up Carol hey Evan
where can I get your t-shirt I know I'm
not wearing a t-shirt today but if you
look in the description you can get the
three version of the tee shirts that I
wear most often and yeah it's the [ __ ]
spring there's regular campaigns and you
can pick the one that kind of best fits
you and if you do get a t-shirt take a
picture take a video with it I'd love to
see it maybe feature it on a video at
some point in the future but yeah if you
check out the description of any of the
newest videos for the past year probably
you can see a link to where they get a
t-shirt next up is Joni I would
pronounce that okay what puzzles me is
why nobody has pre ordered 500 books I
expected that package to be sold out in
the first week and short time felt bad
that I would miss that opportunity
because it would be sold up before it
could afford it had I got the money in
my product ready to sell I would
definitely have got that any first time
entrepreneur with products with target
audiences entrepreneurs should really
get it you get business coaching and
expose you to Evans audience and plenty
of books to give others a situation
change in such a way that this isn't on
my plans anymore sir side the post this
message that someone else might get the
idea Joanie I gotta help him pronounce
that ok really really appreciate that
that's a that's an awesome message is
great to read I get that not everybody's
in a financial position to be able to
afford bigger packages I wanted to be
able to create packages that people
could get a lot of value from where they
were getting way more value than what
they were paying for people have asked
for some coaching I don't do coaching I
don't like to do coaching mostly because
i really enjoy the one on one but i'm
conscious that i want to send my time on
much bigger things and so if i'm
spending time coaching one person i'm
not making a youtube video that can
reach
you know a million people potentially
and so this is that this is a chance to
get me on coaching but I do you know I I
understand that not every was in the
financial position I totally get that
but you know buying one book means a lot
to me to buying 10 books means a lot 25
books means a lot doesn't have to be the
bigger packages the show of support
again no like touches me I really
appreciate it and like the message the
message that you wrote it just is
awesome it touches my heart and I
understand that you're not able to buy
the 500 books but the message alone is
amazing so thank you next up kewley
great now i can tell those that are
blind or with site impairments that
wanted your audio version that it's out
tell them to not pre-release an audio
excludes these individuals and they do
not see true interest as a whole when
they do not I know a lot of sight
impaired individuals and there's a lot
of books they wish for main audio
versions when books were also
pre-release over the initial release
glad to hear you're able to show how
important an audio version was to your
fans yeah you know it's just the nature
of the industry and it sucks I agree
there's a lot of people who can't who
can't who can't see and so they want to
hear the audio version and a lot of
people just don't read books listening
to an audiobook is their preferred path
and so you're asking them to do
something that is totally outside their
norm or what they're comfortable with or
change your schedule around and that
making those roadblocks means that
people will have a harder time saying
yes and if you have something that you
want to get out there you want to reduce
this many roadblocks as fossil make it
easy again with a book publishing
industry it's just not standard to
release the audio version in pre-launch
is usually just comes out on a date
which I which sounds crazy I don't get
it so many people want to hear the
e-book so that they can listen to all
their working out or walking or on the
subway or driving in the car you know
you have an option to listen to it
instead of just reading it and I don't
know why they don't I don't know why
it's not standard I'm glad that we were
able to force the the exception the
force you know something different I
self to look in the iBooks now because
that was a comment earlier up but i
don't know i don't get it i agree a
hundred percent with your point and you
know for entrepreneurs you want to make
it easy as easily possible to be able to
get your product out there next up
Stefan or Stefan it's not about the cost
it's not about a price is about an
investment your book and from what I
hear and see about it
is definitely worth the investment
required to read and grow feeling the
love I love coming to the comments of
these videos you guys really make my day
every every time yeah books are books
much more than the cost of any book not
just my book but any book is the cost of
your time to read it if the book costs
twenty dollars or whatever it costs if
you spend eight hours reading it ten
hours reading it 20 hours reading it how
much is that 20 hours really that's
that's a dollar an hour no yes twenty
dollars reading it is is a dollar an
hour how much is your time worth you're
giving up a lot of times to put into
yourself and hopefully that book that
you're reading will have a major impact
I'm super pumped because the book you
know the book that I've given to my
audience like the test subject the test
audience as well as the little mini
experience that I've run on people
around me has been insane has been
amazing and the book was twice as long
so we cut a lot of the content the not I
don't say the fact is still really good
content but the stuff that's left is the
best of the best of what we gave out to
everybody else I'm not even so worried
about hitting the best of the list I
know it's like a goal that every author
has has never been my like you know my
publisher wants to hit the list and all
that it's great it's a good recognition
I want the book to come out and I wanted
to change people's lives I want people
to have a greater sense of purpose I
want people to have better self
awareness found people to understand the
path that they're on and now make
decisions with clarity instead of
second-guessing themselves or being
unsure of what to do next and giving
them a blueprint that can really help
them I'm so excited for the impact that
the book is going to have by people
reading it and applying it and then
creating wealth for themselves and had
create an impact for themselves much
more than I hope we can sell X number of
books I know it's part of the game but
my to motivation comes from the
investment that I hope you guys make and
did not just bind the book of reading
the book and then even harder apply in
the book where how many books have you
read and they look great book and you
get inspired but you don't do anything
and then you know the next week you
totally forgot about it you're on to
something else I would hate that there's
gold in this book that you need to apply
to your business in your life and I'm
super excited to share the stories and
going to keep on you guys to actually
apply the lessons because if you do it
some of its hard work some of it is
breaking your limiting beliefs and
breaking the
habits that you had that may be holding
you back it's work but if you do it it's
you know the most important work of all
a bunch of guys also left comments
saying that you pre-ordered the book on
audible thank you guys means a lot to me
I'm glad we can make that happen for you
so that's a quick update for this week I
love to know what you think I love to
know your thoughts on adding value and
how to do it and how you doing in your
business if you have a question for me
about the book or the book writing
process leave in the comments below and
I'll do my best to answer next week I
also want to give a quick shadow to
Antoine clerk renault fellow Canadian
from Quebec Thank You Antoine for
picking up my book really means a lot to
me if you guys watching you want a
chance at a shadow in the future video
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
you know the drill email in your seat
and we can keep track send you the
bonuses thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and I'll see you soon